a lot of talk about both Dean and Peter
for bachelor how do you think either of
those guys would do it'd be great both
of them yeah do a bachelors you've done
it once before would you ever pit two
one against another again no I I won't
allow that to happen again we will not
do that again it's such a pain in the
butt but no those are those are
obviously two strong candidates Dean
Peter Brian Eric there's four great
candidates right there but in all
seriousness we've not picked a bachelor
so I can tell you no bachelor was chosen
we're gonna wait for the Bachelorette to
end and then we're gonna wait for a
bachelor paradise to kind of run its
course as well because Nick popped out
of paradise last year if you remember we
didn't see that coming we weren't
planning on it and then it happened so I
think you know lesson learned we're
gonna wait and just watch it all play
out we don't start taping for quite some
time so there's no reason
I know people would love for us to
announce it but there's no reason to we
would just be jumping the gun so we're
gonna we're gonna wait
[Music]